non
bonsoir à tous alors moi il fait froid
dehors je vous propose pendant quelques
petites minutes de partir en afrique du
sud à la pointe de l'afrique du sud il y
a deux ans je me promenais dans les
townships de l'afrique du sud
un soir et subitement je tombe sur un
groupe de jeunes hommes aux visages
réjouis faisant la fête
alors je me rapproche d'un 2 et je leur
demande pourquoi ils sont tous contents
comme ça il me répond c'est notre
premier jour de travail
aujourd'hui nous avons obtenu ce travail
grâce à une formation que nous avons
suivi alors moi très étonnée je lui
réponds mais comment as tu pu avoir
cette formation puisque en afrique du
sud n'y a pas d'argent vous savez qu'en
afrique du sud
c'est l'un des pays les plus touchés par
la crise financière dans les pays
émergents et un certain nombre de
secteurs sont encore en cours de
recherche de stabilité alors il me
répond mais voilà comment ça s'est passé
un soir il ya un professeur d'école qui
m'appellent et qui me propose cette
formation pour non formés aux métiers de
l'énergie
ce sont des compétences que l'on manque
en afrique du sud et le financement
qu'il a obtenu de cette formation était
simplement grâce à une société française
qui a répondu à un appel d'offres qui a
voulu s'implanter en afrique du sud et
en contrepartie le gouvernement
sud-africain leur demander de s'investir
dans le domaine de l'éducation de la
formation et puis très ému il me précise
sans cette contrepartie finalement nous
n'aurions pas eu cette formation qui
nous a permis quand même de former 1500
sud africains dont 20 ont pu venir
pendant un an à la sorbonne
ouah intrigué par la conversation en de
ses collègues n'ont rejoint et vient à
son tour me préciser une autre histoire
en me disant en 1999
il ya une société sud africaine qui est
créé qui est donc l'une filiales de
grands groupes français spécialisé dans
le design le développement des produits
photovoltaïques
or dans les pays en voie développement
ces produits de photovoltaïque sont très
importants notamment pour des régions
pour prouveur produire de l'électricité
et justement rejoindre des régions
isolées
il me précise donc que quand c'est aux
sociétés sud africaines a été créé le
gouvernement sud-africain demander à
nouveau des contreparties et ses
contreparties économiques se sont
manifestés notamment pour ce cas là par
le fait que la société française a
investi dans le capital de la société
sud africaine et a subvenu aux besoins
de fonds de roulement on appelle ça pour
ceux qui ont des entreprises et
conclusions aujourd'hui ce que ça donne
cette société sud-africaine emploie plus
de 210 personnes et par rapport à son
chiffre d'affaires originel qui était
prévue de 10 millions est aujourd'hui à
plus de 6 millions d'euros 100 millions
d'euros waouh
toutes ces histoires sont vraies alors
je me demande mais comment ces jeunes
gens ont pu bénéficier de formations
davantage économique simplement par
l'implantation d'une société française
dans leur pays
alors je réfléchis en tant que lobbyiste
et spécialiste en financement européen
en financement public
je réalise tout simplement qu'ils
avaient bénéficié de contreparties
économiques de compensation économique
on dit en anglais sauf 7 puisque qu'est
ce qui s'est passé en réalité les deux
sociétés françaises qui ont répondu à
travers des appels d'offres ont gagné
ces marchés se sont implantées en
afrique du sud est la contrepartie les
offset que demandait le gouvernement
s'était simplement de s'impliquer de
créer de la valeur ajoutée dans leur
pays notamment d'entre cap en afrique du
sud et je me dis il reste encore
beaucoup de zones aujourd'hui dans notre
monde où il se passe des choses dont on
perçoit pas forcément les mécanismes
mais qui permettent quand même aux gens
de pouvoir se relier entre les pays du
nord et les pays en voie développement
mais avant de poursuivre laissez moi
vous expliquer un peu mieux ce qu'est ce
mécanisme des compensations économiques
les compensations économiques ce sont
simplement des mesures dont qui sont
utilisés par certains états aujourd'hui
48 états dans le monde qui oblige qui
impose aux sociétés qui veulent exporter
dans leur pays qui veulent s'implanter
dans leur pays qui impose des
contreparties
c'est à dire vous venez je passe
commande chez vous en revanche vous vous
engagez à venir développer dans mon pays
et donc un certain nombre davantage au
regard des dispositifs aujourd'hui
économique
nous sommes dans un monde dans la crise
financière de 2008 continue à perdurer
dans une tension économique tant dans
les pays du nord que dans les pays en
voie de développement est aujourd'hui lé
avantages de ces compensations
économiques c'est que justement ça
permet de contribuer au développement
local notamment des pays en voie de
développement encore donc des solutions
ça fait des siècles qu'on entend parler
des pays en voie de développement
on essaie toujours de trouver des
solutions pour pouvoir leur faire
rattraper leur niveau et en l'occurrence
on met deux histoires qui sont des
histoires vraies d'ailleurs ces
compensations l'afrique du sud avait
simplement demandé ces compensations
pour pouvoir rattraper l'injustice
économique qui avait été créé lors de
l'apartheid qui était je vous rappelle
arrêté en 1993 alors je me suis dit et
finalement il reste encore des choses à
faire
la compensation économique
elle permet tout simplement d'atteindre
des objectifs économiques en faisant
quoi en permettant de soutenir des
industries clé puisque nos sociétés une
pme françaises notamment peuvent aller
exporté sécuriser l'environnement social
notamment en afrique du sud va quand
même permis d'avoir de l'emploi tant de
maintenir le développement économique de
certaines régions
ça permet également aussi d'exporter nos
technologies
tout simplement donc c'est profitable
aux deux parties à la société qui veut
exporter puisque ça lui permet de
continuer son activité industrielle à
l'international aujourd'hui nos
gouvernements nous disent pour les pme
il faut exporter à l'aide internationale
donc ces composants de composantes
économiques sont des solutions pour cent
et le pays qui en bénéficient
lui se retrouve avec une possibilité de
nouer des alliances stratégiques avec
des entreprises multinationales
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça on se dit
oui mais dans quelle mesure - quand j'ai
compris ça quand j'ai compris l'ampleur
du phénomène je me suis dit bon fond
elle tue et lobbyistes lobby c'est quoi
c'est défendre les intérêts des
entreprises auprès des pouvoirs publics
pour s'assurer d'une prise en compte de
leurs intérêts or dans le monde des eaux
fait il est important de comprendre le
fonctionnement
l'environnement politique du pays dans
lequel on va je me suis dit ensuite en
tant que spécialiste en financement
européen j'accompagne les porteurs de
projets les pme les collectivités à
pouvoir identifier des opportunités de
financement pour leurs projets de
développement
or la compensation économique et d'un
support de financement très innovant
aujourd'hui et qui est très très peu
connu et pourtant rares sont ses sujets
qui dans un monde globalisé permettent
de pouvoir combiner l'activité
économique à travers les marchés publics
internationaux et l'activité extra
économiques c'est-à-dire contribuer au
développement local des pays en voie de
développement
et quand j'ai réalisé ce phénomène jeu
j'avais l'impression d'être sur un
trésor vous savez comme dans un petit bd
de picsou je suis sous un coffre fort
je sens qu'il ya de l'or on ne voit pas
c'est fermé et ça rayonne sur les côtés
treize jeunes je me suis dit se passe
quelque chose alors je suis pas resté
insensible et j'ai réalisé en attendant
ces deux histoires que moi aussi je
pouvais peut-être contribué apporter ma
pierre apporter ma pierre pourquoi
puisque aujourd'hui on voit l'écart se
creuse et on voit les difficultés d'un
certain en pays de pouvoir rattraper les
écarts on sait que les marchés publics
ces 1000 milliards aujourd'hui
en termes de chiffre d'affaires et on se
dit comment permettre de réconcilier ces
mécanismes économiques nos entreprises
multinationales européennes ou
américaines ont soif de pouvoir se
développer continuer la production
industrielle et permettre en pays en
voie de développement dans bénéficier
mais d'une manière apaisée et régulé
alors quand j'ai compris tout ça je me
suis dit bon apporter ma pierre dans un
dispositif aussi complexe aussi subtile
permettra une pme aussi petite qu'elle
soit d'aller s'implanter en inde
aujourd'hui ces 48 pays qui pratiquent
les offset dans le monde alors tout ceci
après l'histoire après ces deux
histoires je me suis dit j'ai décidé de
rejoindre l'association eco & co kg
european club comme ce trail d977 une
association internationale qui rassemble
les différents acteurs impliqués dans
les compensations international est
depuis un an j'ai la chance et la fierté
de diriger auprès de la banque mondiale
une communiste de pratiques qui vise à
rassembler l'ensemble des partenaires
concernés par le sujet donc des
universités au japon des avocats
américains des des institutionnels des
organisations institutionnelles où l'on
cherche
on réfléchit pour réguler ces pratiques
et de temps en temps pour pouvoir
proposer des standards une espèce de loi
mondiale espèce de frombork
d'architecturé qui permettrait de
légaliser ces pratiques ce genre de
financement de coopération internet
nal alors pourquoi avoir la nécessité de
le réguler tout simplement parce que
chaque pays aujourd'hui
si vous allez en inde l'inde va exiger
des contreparties économiques on regarde
sa problématique si vous allez au brésil
ça sera encore autre chose si vous allez
en russie ce sera encore autre chose et
bien évidemment ce sont aussi des
occasions potentielles de corruption et
notre objectif et mon objectif
aujourd'hui à la hauteur de ce que je
peux y contribuer avec le peu de
prétention que je peux avoir dans ce
monde globalisé
c'est de faire en sorte que l'on puisse
avoir des guides de bonnes pratiques de
se dire aujourd'hui
eh ben la compensation économique ça
draine des milliards certes mais face à
l'argent ça répond à des problématiques
humaines derrière ça permet de sécuriser
l'emploi
ça permet de soutenir des industries
clés et ça apporte des vraies solutions
à l'humanité d'avoir une économie
mondiale apaisé en tout cas réguler et
transparente et donc nous sommes partis
donc pour trois ans pour cette réflexion
et de mon objectif je reviens juste de
la banque mondiale la semaine dernière
et mon objectif c'est vraiment de faire
en sorte que d'ici deux ou trois ans
nous puissions avoir une régulation
mondiale sur ce sujet pour pouvoir
justement faire en sorte que les hommes
puissent enfin à travers l'économie
arrivé à collaborer ensemble en tout cas
moi c'est ce que j'ai décidé de faire de
contribuer d'apporter ma pierre et
j'espère qu'il en sera de même pour vous
merci de votre attention